what i'm going to do in this video is
give a very high level
history of some of the significant
events in judaism and i will use the
word history loosely because historians
aren't able to really find a lot of
evidence for some of what i'm going to
talk about before the first millennium
bce these stories we get from the first
five books of the hebrew bible often
referred to as the torah also the first
five books of the old testament also we
get them from the muslim quran
but there isn't a lot of historical
evidence for them and so many historians
view it more along the lines of legend
but there are many people who view these
as historic facts and have attempted to
place them on a historic timeline and
what i'm going to do in this video is
i'm going to
attempt to fit onto this historic
timeline where some of those
the people who believe it did happen
where they when they believed it
happened but keep
keep in mind that there's not a lot of
strong archaeological evidence
historical record here and these
accounts were written several hundred
years after when they were purported to
occur
so let's start in the beginning let's
start in the book of genesis in the
torah and the hebrew bible and the old
testament and i'm not going to go into
detail on the book of genesis it starts
of course with god
the the monotheistic god creating the
the heavens and earth and then we have
the stories of adam and eve and then
several generations later the story of
the great flood of noah and then noah's
son shem and i talk about shem because
this is where the word semitic comes
from you might refer to you might have
heard people refer to jewish people as
semitic but also arab people are
referred to as semitic because according
to biblical accounts they are both
viewed as descendants of abraham who is
a descendant of shem so they are viewed
as semitic
the first real significant patriarch of
the hebrew bible is considered
abraham who i just mentioned
and it has abraham moving from or uh
from from the city of orr and there's
debate on which or that is it might be
the ancient sumerian
city in in lower mesopotamia or some
people believe that it was an ore in
upper mesopotamia but regardless of
which account you take and once again
abraham is considered by many historians
as a legendary figure so there's not
clear evidence that he existed in a
historical sense but if you take the
accounts in the old testament and the
hebrew bible he would have gone with his
family from orr
and eventually migrated to canon which
is in near or around modern-day israel
lebanon palestine that general area so
it's either from this or
or that or
and
abraham is considered the first of the
three significant patriarchs for the
jewish people the other two are isaac
and jacob and once again i could do a
whole series of videos on the stories of
abraham but abraham's first son is
ishmael who he has with the servant of
his wife sarah after they determined
that they're not able to or they don't
think that they're able to have children
and according to biblical accounts
ishmael is viewed as the progenitor as
the patriarch of the arab people but
later in life
abraham and at this point he is roughly
100 years old and his wife sarah
according to biblical accounts is in her
90s they have isaac who is considered a
significant patriarch in judaism
and this is the famous this is a
painting by rembrandt of the famous
abraham being willing to sacrifice his
son isaac but then he gets stopped at
the last minute
but it's viewed as a sign of his
willingness to his faith in god and his
willingness to follow god now isaac's
son is jacob and jacob is later named by
god as israel and so this is where the
word israelites come from and even the
modern state of israel
now one of jacob's son is joseph and
once again is according to biblical
accounts there isn't a lot of historical
evidence here but it's a fascinating
story the story of joseph how he is sold
by his brothers into slavery and taken
from canon
to
to egypt but joseph
once again fascinating story is
eventually able to rise through the
ranks become the vizier of egypt and
later his family including jacob come to
egypt when there's a famine in canon and
that is the explanation for the biblical
settlement of a significant fraction of
the israelites in egypt but then they
are enslaved and according to biblical
accounts they are enslaved for 400 years
over 400 years and that's what you see
in this green line right over here and
they stay enslaved in egypt
until we get to moses who is considered
the most significant of the prophets in
the jewish tradition and one of the very
most significant prophets amongst
christians and muslims
so let's get to moses
so moses story once again one of these
famous stories how the pharaoh is get
feeling threatened by the growing
population of the jewish people who
remember are enslaved and so as the
story goes he orders all newborn hebrew
jewish boys to be killed but moses's
mother hides moses and he puts them
on a on a basket in the nile and the
pharaoh's daughter discovers him and
raises moses and so he's able to get an
education and is part of the royal court
of the pharaoh
but later in life he sees a slave master
that's abusing a jewish person to death
and then he kills a slave master and so
he's afraid for his life and so he runs
away
fearing the penalty for killing the
slave master
and he goes to mount sinai or mount
horeb and this is where we think the
biblical mounts this is where the
current mount sinai mount horeb is and
that's where we think the biblical one
might have been and that's where we have
the story of the burning bush where he
is commanded by god who is kind of the
angel of the lord is speaking through
this bush and telling moses go back and
you need to free the jewish people from
enslavement
and so he does go back
and he is able to liberate them and once
again this is a very famous story and
the pharaoh's armies follow him he parts
the red sea the pharaoh's army is
eventually destroyed and he takes the
jewish people back to mount sinai and
mount horeb
when these are sometimes viewed as two
different mountains sometimes the same
mountains different sides of the same
mountains we are not exactly sure but
most people view them as the same
mountain and it was at mount sinai mount
horeb where now with now moses is able
to receive the famous 10 10 commandments
and he's able to receive the jewish laws
and the first five books of the hebrew
bible the torah the pentateuch the the
first five books of the old testament
genesis exodus leviticus numbers and
deuteronomy these the authorship of
these is ascribed to
moses
so once moses and and once again
historians really debate that but this
is what this is according to biblical
accounts
now once he receives this this word of
god he then takes the jewish people they
set up a tabernacle they go through the
desert for 40 years and he brings them
to the promised land and before entering
moses dies but he essentially is able to
resettle the jewish people back in canon